we got our first match here the
roommates the roomies playing against
each other a match of roommates and and
brothers you know they these guys are
like best friends right here so you know
well until somebody loses and then it's
gonna be like alright well you pay rent
this month and I'm not gonna deal with
it and also I'm not taking out the trash
when I get home I see it the kid who's
five oh yeah kid booze 5l he's holding
it out I mean that's the button he's
about to deal with right now
oh yeah right off the bat maybe yeah
knock Yola he's not good weekend so far
lost top eight qualifier but made it in
a loser side playing pretty pretty solid
I think this weekend you know when he's
on point he is a tough tough man to beat
I just think he's got to be off the more
I his team and the way he plays like if
he's not playing perfect I feel like it
really affects him you know what I mean
he's like one of those players that has
a lot you know kind of expectations that
he sets on himself although I think sage
is similar as well I think that both of
them can sometimes get inside there are
their own heads about the way that they
play but in the end they both are very
very strong players so this is going to
be quite the match to see I can see this
being a go going to Game three yeah
definitely I mean used to play a lot too
right like you know I'm sure this is
your roommate you're you see him once or
twice walking down the hall I go it's
you again
I forgot you live here too oh yeah it's
gonna be fun to watch these two you it's
cool to see them out here rubbing the
East Coast
obviously right the East Coast battle
yeah you know the two East Coast players
out there it's cool I mean I've seen
sage streaming a lot too lately and
Knockhill as well they both stream and
despite streaming you know they're not
too lazy to just stay home and spam HGG
Guapo's and
you know actually come out so
tournaments like this and in Puerto Rico
so that's really cool to see and you
know we'll see who's gonna tuck their
shirt in this first the loser's bracket
match ooh yeah kill sage got a master
the square button in this one
yeah it's true yes true I mean to be
fair there's some solid light lights on
the other team - not as crazy as to go
on level one
Gohan yeah I mean about these Gohan's
right it's like you know one of them's
got a level up and that's important and
that takes a lot of like resources and
you know the middle about how you play
the team and the other one not so much
rough black dragon rush early I was
trying to be the aggressive one at the
beginning here I mean that's you know
math knowledge knowing if he's gonna
cancel the legs and I and that's the
mind game they're gonna have to play do
you reflect after the light light or do
you just block and respect the leg
pencil so here's the situation if light
light light right and then after that
it's like weather tingles gonna do
something gonna hold the vanish get the
calm though so I think Nakia was
expecting legs and a pressure or
whatever and I think those sparking
makes sense in that case yeah I can
agree with it in that situation and he
was able to get out of his situation he
was in after all and manages to get this
hit on Super Saiyan Goku going into the
lake drop the combo I think you missed
the jump first more the dragon rush
maybe I'm not sure about this whopper
Nakia still he's back hit boo assist
again guard cancel yeah yeah that was
the right time the guard cancel good per
se just call that out now yell backing
off throwing the people ass in the air
yeah you know when you watch these two
play it's very funny right because
chingon has these big ki blast the two H
ting go on that's big ki blast even
really really strong a neutral for sure
and that's one difference between him in
adult Gohan you'll notice when those two
characters are fighting which legs
[Music]
great defense will get hit by the low
gets opened up by it you're gonna see
him dragged to the corner that was
awesome defense wouldn't say it's not
easy to bark level one two three
no he's gonna take a level up into the
knock down off the kid buu okay goes in
with the heavy legs here deep he's out
reflect from nap yelled to H from the
kill stage yeah I think a bit of a
mistake there too gave it that one away
with the Banat yeah the right I did see
those aged legs I think we're supposed
to call out the marking on wakeup maybe
but it should be the kill DP level one
one more that'll do it yeah bring out
Super Saiyan Goku Gohan is out of here
and that is a hard hit for a team Mac
Yale obviously one of the best adult
Gohan's that we have in the scene yeah
especially I mean you know in that
corner situation he had blocked DP e in
Spanish and then he ended up getting
punished for it that's definitely a a
rough swing mix-up
I really like the defense I'm seeing
here from Achilles aid you can
definitely tell these two play a lot
especially with the patience
against kid buu weird TK coming home
I'll show what cuts what he tried run a
key blasts gumball and meelo on the
other side 6m hits but nothing dragon
rush that's the only thing that is gonna
open up because everything else did not
yell tried just failed
yeah and that's like the one thing that
really led to something have to write
reflect tag wow it actually get to eat
enough yeah you stayed in the front five
bars on deck here for the kill stage
level one one bringing out team Gohan
again to deal with this little care
right here well how's the big wimp but
eh legs err - over yeah he's so small
that that's actually kind of hard to hit
on no reflects on the gumball
that's definitely like a deer in
headlights moment where if you do it a
little too early you for getting it but
you know you need to this should be the
kill now oh my oh my gosh
if you just go and get this kill on team
velocity PT right in this situation
always just challenge with a but there's
a spark man this character should be
dead light light light tag out yeah I
like the tag out there you're gonna get
a little bit of blue house bags and a
team go on another day
goes no mystic ball combos off of it
snap ringing teen gohan bring him back
in he's so close to death if he knock
you up and secure one more hit oh yeah
it doesn't get him out or anything but
challenge mystic ball with sniper yes
it's like teen go on shoots rockets out
of his hands when you see him do is keep
up there so fast they're very good too
waited out the reflects super - pull the
trade in the air but make work and get
Brit up teen gohan
yeah and that was good of him to realize
that he didn't use me to use mystic ball
just a ski blast into the porcelain
courthouse right off here yeah nice work
I think knock yield did a good job of
like composing right he had a couple of
drops but really kind of like reined it
back together and now he's got a full
help Brawley against his [ __ ] oh yeah
and when he got to hit with GT Goku he
was able to capitalize right off then
get rid of him now drag rush on Broly
gonna bring him into the corner which is
a good spot to have this big tight armor
ban - oh so in that moment you can hit
as many buttons right you got to be
careful but then the vanish should
always be a pretty consistent answer
with armor it's good a schematic
knowledge from
it's mystic ball hit at the tail end for
the kill reversal level 3 I think he's
blocking despite the key blast being out
on the screen already that's the killing
game one game one goes Funaki oh yeah
definitely
a bunch of props for sure really
affecting that set but you know I think
you did a good job of not panicking
right there's a lot of moments that
could have been really really bad really
quick but uh yell together and I think
that's important in to sound like this
even if you make some mistakes keep your
composure that's the one great thing
about both of these players they both
managed to even when things are not
looking good keep their composure in a
game yeah hard to do I'm sure you miss
stuff you're like come on how did I drop
2lh super dad for the extension
it's good a good knowledge of Akio just
double down Brian hope that he misses it
it's worth a try I think you block or
you double jump out I wonder if it's a
little bit safer to ochita go because of
how shiny yeah the chances of him
hitting the incoming I mean you might as
well try here in the corner block that
actually which is why I got a button man
drama Ken know it happens you hate to
see it but it does happen
there we go keeping it safety assist
rolling it this out going to hit the
dragon rush we're gonna be a knockdown
there are six bars on deck here we go
level 1 level 1 yeah I was gonna say I
imagine you got to get Broly in here
you didn't really play too much last
time to tell you as a solo snatch up
here we go
I love it I love it yeah it hurts it's a
very scary command throw and you know
that's part of what makes this character
so dangerous if you just like staggers
and then you try to vanish to beat it or
something I need to ages you he's very
very good character
you get the hit and goes right into the
heavy legs yeah this was a lot of damage
to the corner it's like they it is the
leg thing here we go snap out bringing
kids who get the suit in yeah from not
gonna counter that I think I think nah
keel is doing a great job when he is
being snapped in just to making sure
he's doing whatever he can to not have
to use that spark and get out of sticky
situation yeah because if you sit there
and block I mean you might just die and
dying is probably not the goal right
it's we're just giving it a shot the
worst thing that happens you block right
you double jump it doesn't work you
block it it's not the end of the world
that's where you were gonna be anyway
mix up and yeah you got a spark off the
gumball
yeah because page was actually somebody
who used to play adult go on for quite
some time so he probably knows when it's
not the situation that you want to hold
that against him yeah I mean if you
block on ball and this character you're
fighting has real mix up so you
definitely want to block it big damage
off this level juice markings on the
elbow easy peasy kill
he'll page down to his last two
characters sparking not quite out yet
for nap yell but going around eventually
yeah it's gonna start flashing pretty
soon here so you know but it gets a
super - in on Broly gonna snap out
bringing Tim go on get rid of this
little tyrant in his Auto combo - mix-up
goes all overhead stagger low and I like
that challenge sage
yeah you got to drop some meter here I
think level 3 expensive oh not enough to
kill though well he does manages to get
Kid Buu out of there are we gonna see
snapper or we're just gonna try now just
go to level 1
and if your knock you'll hear all the
big TP whip and a dragon rush for the
opponent right to the other side great
and pops him out of the sky there two
killed kid blue sitting on low health
here to kill sage looking strong yeah
this looks great and this is not an easy
character get in again especially with
no assists but I mean sometimes you
exactly that hatefully first turn here
well that was a Miss yeah for sure no
punish though oh I think that's the
perfect way to end this one right here
tying it up one one yeah the best part
is like you just see the character
walking back like waiting for whatever's
gonna happen and then you're like well
he got grabbed for her was I saying this
could be up Game three yeah he has a
game three we'll see what the Stars
gonna be both these point characters are
really really explosive scary characters
in the front nice block but wasn't ready
to punish it
I stomp on the ground under the
assistant that assists people have
gotten really good at challenging under
it because it's not you know it doesn't
take up the ground space then people act
like it does both characters but you go
on fella that's low you want to fall out
there does not take the snap dragon both
of them but they fell out again there's
a lot of blue life on the screen gets
hit he's dead it's really bad because
you get the kill and then he immediately
comes in with blue life and you get the
level up on go on
now can y'all start out really strong
here not even commentators first there
we go
rolling minutes to make it happen float
now like a buttons from na kill and this
is a bad spot air - yeah sparks out - am
starter yeah I like the delay there lady
this is gonna hurt
stomp down in the uppercut he's like if
you're just gonna win I'm just gonna TP
through snap out bring in Super Saiyan
go on go gumballs out lockdown oh oh
yeah we seen that a few times but not go
so far legs how about another wrap and
then bring them off leg day 1 level 3 a
lot of damage and the sparking gone now
Nakia still sitting on spark 2 which
makes pretty much any combo he hits very
very scary that will land level 3 all
blue line he might spark up actually to
get the blue life back we'll see you may
be on Tipperary here
clothes for the 2m there gets the okay
yeah kid buu got too much blue life I
think for him to just kind of sit there
and let it die super - it a little lame
you could have maybe got it if you did
it faster off to go hannes s knock
Yeltsin doing a really good job to it
those pieces there goes beaucoup just
like that you try to get him out I like
that idea from stage but the vanish is a
good looking really good could be
eliminating to kill stage right now back
stomp and the child okay that's a big
one I cannot believe that hit up you're
saying that's a big even say there's
anything that's not big right now
I mean Rowley I cannot believe that
Tabriz oh my god try to detect the
command role white level three the pink
matter from the palm rope not field tech
a command throw he's like I'm sorry he's
like I love you I love you man they live
with each other around they have to they
have to live with this it just cracks me
up because like he legit tech the
command throw like thank you legit just
take the command but like they say it's
not possible by still hot on the screen
the he came out and he was like dragon
run hi everybody's done that they've all
tried it they've all been like that's
definitely gonna be a dragon rush we try
break it you're like oh it worked out
I'll take him why not perfect I've seen
some crazy matches already yeah the best
part is like on our screen I the first
thing I did when I saw it was I looked
at na keels face and he was like like on
this thick II couldn't believe I have it
it was too good that's one thing I don't
do enough when we're when we're looking
at the screen I'm so into the game that
I'm not also looking at these crazy
moments at their faces because I'm I'm
not used to there being so many cameras
it's like extra yeah it's like a chichi
you get to see there